a couple leaving is Sasha and Gleb
[Music]
you are so good tonight I think we're
all shocked and you're mad oh I'm not
mad I just I'm really bummed I really
wanted to be here so you know it sucks
but I made some amazing friends and such
a good time and I know I feel like I'm
just grateful I'm grateful for him the
opportunity so he can't get away from me
that easy he's gonna teach my fiancee
how to dance wedding right but I think
going into tonight if you were to ask
people like oh who do you thinks gonna
go home tonight you guys weren't even on
that list if people that possibly could
happen to so what happened well I it's
it's a shock you know I never thought it
would happen I thought we have another
couple of weeks at least but it's a
dance competition someone's gotta go
home and unfortunately this is us you
know I'm so proud of my partner she came
so far she did such a good job tonight
you've shown such a huge improvement in
them as a teacher I'm really really
proud of you thank you my question is
this this has been transformative for
you not only did you say today you lost
37 pounds but also that you felt like
yourself again and it really has been an
incredible experience it's been amazing
for my soul for like me just getting
back to Who I am obviously for my body
and my health I'm just really glad that
I was able to have the platform to talk
about my situation and I had so much fun
[Music]
you